lecce bancari musa ax prima
l'ultimo giro
ultimo giro se ne aspettano un po di
giri sono io
buonasera
infatti vedere una cosa perché visto che
siamo qua al bar è fatto per sfogarsi io
volevo e guida con prudenza bomba della
la personala pure questione testa roma
ti spacca davvero proprio di fiori come
argomento e ai fan piace per qualche
ragione a me fa schifo perché funziona
ci sono delle scene belle 2 crescere ma
ovviamente lì mi sono scontrato con ciò
vissuto boris puoi fare questa cosa se
non la vita il minore di 14 anni in un
po diventasse quale l'organo
sceneggiatore cm con noi un giorno che
poi scrivere la storia della nostra vita
detto questo però su certe cose
anticipato anche max cioè la guerra
ovviamente tutto annacquato qualche rete
piacere tutto non pochino tanto proprio
quasi affogato silva sta per uno che ama
i film come me
questo è un tasto dolente ecco che però
negli anni ho imparato anche a
sopportare prima cioni mai parlare del
film bene sono passati anche tanti anni
voglio dire sì al comando del fatto che
sono passati tanti anni lo rende
digeribile adesso che diceva che mara 20
anni fa e quel periodo lì io ero
giovanissimo e andava l'oratorio e mi
son ritrovato dei dei modi di dire
incredibili che io non ho mai sentito
nel cinema italiano dire cazzo di buddha
non l'ho mai io lo dicevo sempre
all'oratore stato incredibile no cazzo
di buddha
[Musica]
nel 2015 tuoi fatto sorci verdi
se io ho litigato su twitter quasi
diciamo che mi hai messo un po in liga
hai fatto bene perché era un po uno
stronzo però io ho guardato con piacere
tutte le puntate poi ho scritto un tweet
che diceva tutta questa satira
trasgressive avanguardistica a soci e
verdi non fa altro che farmi rimpiangere
luttazzi la cosa bella di questo dialogo
qua e che io scrissi a luttazzi
lui mi rispose in privato per la prima
volta ero io stavo morendo e mi ha
scritto grazie mille col punto grazie
mille
una cosa che mi lascia bene da sorci
verdi che quasi tutti quelli che a parte
partecipato a sorci verdi
nel cast sono diventati famosi che vero
formiche la giro fabio lovatti road
antibes dal colica le coliche è comunque
faceva adesso non voglio fare noi sembra
che faccio polemica però ci sono
direction molto avviati che vanno avanti
da anni che non fanno l'audience i sorci
verdi perché oggi dopo tre anni sono
andato per 3 4 mesi
un esaurimento nervoso e non lo dico
l'esaurimento nervoso d'artista cioè il
proprio esaurimento nervoso perché ci
avevo messo tutto me stesso la cosa più
brutta di questo rumore quando metti
tutto te stesso e ci provi coi denti con
le unghie e poi va veramente tutte merda
quindi per tre mesi nei mesi nel garage
a fare 1 elaboratissimo villaggio
natalizio signore con si e poi mi sono
ripreso poi sai cos'è ho scoperto una
roba da lì pensavo fosse una macchia per
sempre invece ho scoperto che in italia
c'è il pubblico alan sign quindi dopo
tre mesi sono dimenticati ci serve
figurati sul web è ancora bene una
settimana
[Musica]
visto che hai parlato del ritorno che si
parla un po di solito articolo volevo
farti vedere una come caccia stavamo
guarda è tutto bello abbronzato
io lui è infranto ma non hai paura che
possa diventare un pochino la minaccia
fantasma di star wars e cioè il grande
ritorno perché mandiamo i pezzi di
allora no si poteva parlando ovviamente
di fare prequel come non ci avete dato
ovviamente articolture quando j ax canta
su una base di gel magari un domani può
succedere assaggiare mi porta una base è
bello ma finirebbe ad un dj anni quindi
tu sei quasi esattamente come appena
arriva un qualcosa che non è andato bene
e finita per almeno 3 4 mesi a sorman e
talmente assolutamente ma ha detto che
volevi chiudere youtube certo punto si
situa il filmato apocalittica e vero è
vero perché dovunque non ce la fai più
le critiche sono una cosa strana
l'inizio dei nori poi nei contesti e
dopo un po ci credi non capiscono molte
volte che l'evoluzione è parte
integrante della coerenza
molte volte un artista stimola
sentimenti forti in un senso o
nell'altro
e anch'io non ho certo artisti problemi
stanno sulle palle a pelle ho capito
perché magari vedono in loro una parte
di me che non mi piace penso che magari
anzi quelli che ogni e più facilmente
diventerà un giorno amico e troverai
appunto un punto di unione
c'è forse tu avessi chiesto allaccio del
93 se uno dei suoi migliori amici
dell'ambiente un giorno sarebbe stato
nec tornato ma sei ma invece è il mac
siamo amicissimi tutti crescono si
cambia tantissimo per cui viviamo in
italia che è una cosa come se una
puntata di black mirror fosse stata
scritta dai vanzina poesia tuo figlio ea
nicolas detto nicolas perché è sempre di
nuca nelle foto quali sono i lati io
voglio sapere quali sono i lati più
lenti [ __ ] non finito perché nessuno
degli artisti ne parla mai tutti lo
romanzo mi va bene va bene perché
parlano da sé che ci vorrei fare un
pezzo però vorrei vorrei poterlo fare
non credo che questo sia un paese giusto
penso che poi brucerebbe per questo dico
sì siamo soli e non è tanto da metterne
i prezzi un po la questione dei tenerlo
in vita questo stava bene sarà un
abbonato di ozzy c'e da un mese ci ha
spiegato esattamente due anni per
cambiare i miei orari che già erano
cambiati rispetto agli anni 90 però un
consiglio da sole sette sono già
operative ma c'è qualcosa che speri che
lui non faccia che tu hai fatto con del
veicolo
spero che quando lui diventerà grande
a parte la marijuana che non la
definisco una droga
spero che non provi tutte le altre
attuale di narrativa
adesso spero che non vadano più di moda
perché io ho avuto le mie esperienze con
con la bianca posso dire che è una merda
il tutto il resto adesso è il minimo
quello adesso sta tornando l'eroina
agenti si parte dal m spero che abbiano
legalizzato la gange magari essere far
qualcosa alla sbarra pisana non si sa
mai
così un infuso dell'infuso poi con il
mostro pato anche questa perché sei
fuori luogo perché sì veramente fuori
luogo
il programmato come se come si dice il
bello essere brutti ecco che un mio
cliente ha chiesto se poi autografare
non è veramente
diciamo che le ragazze degli anni 90
avevano meno pretese che lancerà
instagram the shelf life
mi dicono che zoolander è uscito in
italia nel 2002 sia questo disco del 93
jimmy che ha inventato la maglia
questa è la maglia non argentate blender
certo che sono io che cazzo pensano i
porti che è sempre uguale tra è quello
che era un altro sono io a 0 con la
barba senza pizzo fai conto che ho avuto
difficoltà a riconoscersi in un album
degli articolo 31 grafico da jean
jacques e incolla
siamo a fine serata ormai ti sei sfogano
hai detto tutto quello che devi dire se
vuoi se il libero anche di mandare
affanculo
carissimi prende di sorpresa richiamano
avevo una lista di persone che volevo
mandare affanculo
ma ci sono già andate da sole e quindi
abbiamo mai una fanciulla nessuno
[Musica]